we've done a lot of work on multiplying
adding subtracting inverting matrices so
now let's delve a little into what uh
what a matrix is actually good for and
remember all a matrix is is a a way of
representing data and all of those rules
we learned you can kind of view them as
human created rules there's there's no
fundamental
thing in nature that says matrixes
matrices have to be multiplied the way
we learned but i think you'll you'll see
as as we progress into kind of
applications that that the way that
matrix operations have been defined are
actually quite useful
so let's go back to our
algebra one or algebra two i forget when
you when you tend to learn it but let's
go back to linear equations so what were
linear equations linear systems of
linear equations well you had you know
you had two lines and you essentially
had to figure out where the two lines
intersected so you might have had
something like
let me think of something
three
x
plus
y let's see
is equal to
and then you might have i don't know
minus
x
plus
i don't know 6
y
is equal to i need to do this in my head
just to make sure that i get numbers
that work out well is
this equal to 6.
i think this will work out well
and what what was this problem
essentially well this is a line and this
is a line so you have to figure out
where they intersected and if you were
to
draw those two lines you would well
actually let's draw them just because i
want you to give this is all about
getting intuition and then seeing how it
maps over into made in them into the
matrix world
let's see and the word matrix world has
a whole new meaning after 1999.
let's see so
if that's my coordinate axes
what is this let's if i put this into i
always have to put everything into y
equals mx plus b form for me to have a
so this this equation is what
it's y
is equal to
three halves
x
plus seven halves so seven halves is
what it's like three and a half or
something so if that's seven halves
the it's going to have a slope three and
a half so it's a little bit steeper than
a slope of one so it's going to look
something like that
that's that line
and then
right through seven hash right and then
this line is going to look like what let
me do a different color it's going to
look like see this is the same thing as
y
oh you know what i did that wrong
undo edit undo
okay
because that line i just realized it's
not it's equal to minus 3 halves x plus
7 halves right
because when you take this to the other
side it becomes minus 3x divided by 2.
so it's actually going to be downward
sloping
so it will look something like this
it's going to be a little bit steeper
than something that has a slope of
negative 1. so i'm just approximating
so that line will look something like
that
and this line
let's see this will be
y
z i'm just rewriting this y is equal to
x
plus
one if i'm right yeah because this goes
to the other side six but everything
divided by six
right y is equal to x plus one and so it
would its y intercept will be see we
said this was three three and a half so
maybe if this is one
it has a slope of one
so it'll just look like something like
this
and so when you
when you solve a system of equations
you're essentially looking for
the x and the y values that satisfy both
of these equations right these lines
show us all of this magenta line shows
us all the x and y values that satisfy
this first linear equation
and this green line shows all of the x
and y's that satisfy the second equation
and of course where they intersect
where they intersect shows us the
particular x and y
that satisfies both equations and that's
what we you know that's what we did in
in algebra one two we we wanted to we'd
solve both of these equations
for for that and essentially you know we
we'd we'd multiply we'd either do it by
substitution or we you know we do it by
you know we would
scale them and add them together et
cetera et cetera and as we'll see that's
essentially just what we learned in the
gauss jordan elimination it's the exact
same thing it's just when we did the
gauss-jordan elimination we just
represented a little different but i
think you know this much but let's now
do it in the matrix world
so how can we represent this problem as
a matrix
well we could write it like this and
i'll spend a we'll take out a little
time to prove to you that it really is
the same representation if you define
matrices the way we have to find them in
their multiplication you can define this
problem as
three
minus six
two
six
i just look at the coefficients right 3
minus 6 2 6.
and if i were to multiply that
by
a column vector matrix
x y
and if i were to set that equal to
another column vector matrix
7 6.
now you might want to pause it and and
actually just try to multiply this out
the way that we have learned to multiply
matrices and you will see that you get
the same thing but i will do it now
in case you don't want to do it yourself
so let's just multiply these two
matrices let's multiply this matrix out
and see what happens
so this this is essentially saying
that three
so what do you do you get your row
information from the first matrix column
information from the second matrix so
this is saying three and this is of
course the product matrix so this is
saying three times x plus two times y is
equal to seven well that's exactly what
we wrote up here three times x plus two
times y is equal to seven and similarly
when you multiply the bottom row you get
minus six times x plus 6 times y is
equal to 6. so if that was a little
confusing to you go review how we
multiply matrices but if you just
multiply this out you will get these
exact same equations so hopefully you
understand that this is just another way
of representing this problem although
we've gotten rid of you know the plus
signs and the equal signs but of course
you have to know the representation
but why is this useful
why is this why is this representation
useful
well let's call this
let's call this matrix a
let's call that matrix a
let's call this vector x
it's not a variable it's a vector so
maybe we'll bold it or we could put a
little vector sign there or something
whatever but you'll see it in your
textbook it's bolded real heavy
and then we call this
vector b and the the general the general
notation if i remember correctly is that
you know anything that's a matrix or
vector is bolded
and matrices that are not vectors that
have you know
more than one dimension in either of the
dimensions they're capital letters
while lowercase letters represent
vectors so you know these are matrices
but they're also vectors so that's why
they got the lowercase letters and
that's why this one got the uppercase
letters and that's just convention
but anyway this so this equation has the
form ax equals b where a is this matrix
x is this vector or this matrix the same
thing and b is this column vector
so what does that do for us well what
happens if we knew a inverse
well actually let me take a step back if
this if these were numbers what would we
do if i just gave you an algebra
equation if i just give you an algebra
equation
ax is equal to b
how do you solve that well you would
multiply both sides of this equation you
would divide both sides of this equation
by a right or another way of saying it
you would multiply both sides of this
equation by the inverse of a
so you would essentially say
1 over a
times ax
is equal to
1 over a
times b
and then these would cancel out and you
would get x is equal to b
over a that's how we would do it in a
traditional
you know this this is a traditional
simple linear equation
so how would you do it here well what's
the matrix analogy
to division or by and i'm going to give
you the answer now what's the analogy to
multiplying by your inverse well it's
multiplying by your inverse so what if
we knew the matrix a inverse we could
just multiply both sides of this
equation by a inverse and remember order
matters so it's not like you know when
you're doing a linear equation you could
multiply 1 over a on this side but then
you can do it on the right side here but
no notice i put it in front of the
numbers in both cases so you have to do
it in front of the numbers in both cases
but we know if we know a inverse and if
a inverse exists
then we can multiply both sides you
could say the left side of both sides of
this equation by a inverse so you get a
inverse
a inverse
times a
times the vector x
is equal to
a inverse
times b all i did is i took this
expression i multiplied both sides by a
inverse and what's a inverse times a
well that's just the identity matrix
right
that's the identity matrix
times x
is equal to
a
inverse
b
and of course that's just so x
the identity matrix times any other
matrix is just that matrix so that's
just the matrix x or the vector x
times a
inverse b
so if you're given a linear equation and
if you know the inverse of this matrix
to solve for x and y we just have to
multiply this number times the inverse
and you might say sal that's such a pain
because this is such a simple linear
equation to solve why would i go through
all the trouble of getting an inverse
and then multiplying the inverse times
this number and i would agree to with
you to some degree that for a two by two
uh
system of equations it is easier to
solve it the way that you did it in
in algebra or algebra two
but
if you're doing it for three by three
well finding a matrix is still pretty
difficult for a three by three so it's
still difficult but as you get to larger
and larger numbers it's sometimes well
finding a matrix can be difficult too
but the the
actually the real place where it really
really pays off is let's say that you
have a bunch
of linear equations to to solve
and the left-hand side stays the same
but you keep changing the right-hand
side right so let's say you have ax
equals b and then you have another one
says ax equals c and ax equals d and
these numbers keep changing and these
numbers are the same then it really pays
off to solve for the inverse and then
every time you need to find the new
solution you just multiply your new
right hand side times your inverse and
you just get the answer and that'll
really pay off when we view this in
another way but anyway i wanted to show
you that this is the same thing and so
let's let's solve it let's solve it
using what our knowledge is of matrices
let me erase this here and i know i'm
running over time but
hopefully i'm not completely boring you
so i'm going to keep that there just
because i think it's nice to have that
visual representation of what we're
doing always to remember what's going on
so what's a inverse
so first of all what's the the a and a
inverse
a
inverse is equal to 1
over the determinant of a
times
the adjoint of this matrix i don't want
to get fancy with terminology and all
that but what was that two by two it's
fairly easy you swap these two terms so
you get a six
and a three
and then you make these two terms
negative so net minus six becomes a six
and a two becomes a minus two
and what's the determinant of a
determinant of a
is equal to this times this minus this
times this so three times six
three times six is eighteen
minus this times this so six times two
is twelve but that's a minus six so it's
minus twelve so minus minus twelve
it's equal to
plus
so 18 is equal to 30.
so what does a inverse equal 1 over 30
times this thing so a inverse
a inverse
is equal to we could even keep the 1 out
of 30 on the outside
it might simplify things it well
actually i'll put it so a inverse is
equal to what
this divided by 30 so that's one fifth
minus
minus uh actually you know what i'm
going to well no let me just
actually i do want to keep it on the
outside because it's going to make the
uh
the later multiplications easier
so anyway a is equal to 1 30th
times 6
minus 2
3.
that's a inverse so now let's solve for
x and y so we said x and y is equal to a
inverse times b
so
we could say x another way to write x is
like this
x is just this vector
x and y and not to get confused this x
is different than that x even though
i've written them the same if i was a
typographer i would make this really
bold that you know that this was a
vector maybe i should you know i should
put like a vector notation i don't know
you could do a bunch of things with it
it's equal to a inverse times this so
it's 1 over 30.
i did that just with the matrix addition
i didn't multiply this out so
i didn't divide everything by 30 just
the matrix multiplication is a little
easier minus two
three
times seven sixths
seven
six
and so what is this equal to
equal to one over thirty
times i know i'm crowding this down here
let's see it's 6 times 7 6 times 7
minus 2 times 6.
so 6 times 7
is
right 6 times 7 is 42
minus 2 times 6 so minus 12 so that's
equal to 30
and then 6 times 7 plus 2 times 6. so 6
times 7
once again is 42
plus 2 times 6 so 42 plus 12
is 50
right is that right 6
6 times 7
6 times oh no sorry this is a 3. that's
why i was getting confused i see it's
important to have good penmanship so 6
times 7 is 42
plus 3 times 6
so it's 42 plus 18 which is 60
and of course we divide both of them by
30. so you get you get the final xy i'll
write it here i know i'm i don't want to
erase anything so we get xy
is equal to divide both of those by 30
is equal to
one
and two
and so that tells us that these two
linear equations
intersect at the point x is equal to one
x is equal to one
y is equal to 2.
that might seemed a little bit like a
lot of work but that's just i took the
time to explain all of that but if you
just immediately took that represented
it this way found the inverse and
multiplied it wouldn't have taken you
that much time and i encourage you to do
that as an exercise anyway i'll see you
in the next video and in the next video
we're going to do this exact same
problem but we're going to
we're going to say that this data
represents a different problem see you
soon